yeah hello warzone final time again I'm
joining a minute late missed the start
of the tournament well it's not exactly
the most aggressive setup p.m. against
this reversed Stonewall but at least I
managed to get rid of this this bishop
alright so what should I try to do you
played eform so trying to weaken this
position here this looks nice if he
takes a half night and I deform but he
didn't write very loose play here by
white I hope this doesn't get get to be
a stray dangerous attack by a miracle
possible ok so I think now he needs to
know thought you would need to exchange
ok that's open oh now I'm just winning
the night this is helpful and this is
check out so I'm just light up here
and that's not a parent what white
should have here so now I'm getting rid
of the Queen's the eyes and the spins oh
this night on age three is secure yeah
fortunately he plays on ok now the rook
is gone as well and now I totally won
king and corn endgame still doesn't
resign yeah people somehow don't grasp
the concept that it's actually
advantageous for them also if they just
resign because they get a get a new game
their cells all right this is mid next
move it don't tell me it's letting the
clock run down
yeah amazing this guy simply doesn't
understand the this this tournament
format if he just resins he gets a new
game and can score points this way he
just hurts both of us alright so I can
enter this as a pre moved yeah this
gives me time to fetch some water be
back in a few seconds
alright next game and I'm actually
having some water okay French yeah the
classical line he is playing with be
five a-six and b5 and I'm just playing
this in the traditional manner ok so now
I'm not sure maybe I should have
canceled first ok it's am no no problem
i have this great night aunty form but
i'm in a pin here so this might be a
problem at some point ok so now should I
move the night young knight to e 2 or
somewhere else of course Queen exchange
would be excellent for me Quincy one
maybe I get it get you into f7 yes still
let me try this first maybe he exchanges
oops
I just blundered this porn oh ok so well
this attacks the bishop and friends
Queenie 8 made it wasn't it wasn't
really planned but maybe it is still
somehow playable I can yeah I can get
this check here can advance maybe need
to use some the King here I mean it
doesn't have a square for the bishop and
he cannot protect it yeah can this kind
of Moosa bhai possible so now if I take
with the night Queen e5 czechia yeah
okay Queenie 5 check out quincy
furniture okay so so here I am
I need to speed up here
there's still this mate issue
yeah should I take the draw maybe I
should yeah playing for wind looks a bit
insane here if you place this okay let's
try don't want to consider draw here
it's maybe complete nonsense but
he had still a draw
I don't think I can get out of this okay
next game I'm already pretty cleanly
behind but it's nothing dramatic yet so
he gave me a center which is nice want
to prevent Bishop g5 okay so I is
prepare for you know maybe I should have
done more to prevent this Bishop age six
might be a problem but i hope that i can
use the pin then okay let's exchange him
yeah it's a bit bit annoying this
position okay this is nice nice shot
here can take g3 oh yeah i would have
would have had some nice discover check
and this is made nice this from being
slightly worse to win very quickly or
someone is cheering for me nice okay so
okay 93 was a bit too quickly played
this is not so great against the
scandinavian but now be transposed to a
nice line of the French yeah
unfortunately he prevented this Bishop
g5 stuff winning winning the Queen
okay I still trying to play for the tech
here and maybe if 5 mm maybe can play
five now he has this one also worked ok
I can keep the bishop this costs the
porn but I didn't want to give up the
bishop ok threatening g5 now Oh
hmm weird position it could have maybe
played playdom takes on ship f form okay
stop trying to sacrifice no now i can
simply check here okay h4 h5 opening the
position
still age five right our let's let's
let's prevent on a five and and similar
stuff yeah this is play to prevent you
create for a moment and now pile up on
the chief I'll
okay maybe I can get rid of this rook
Queen takes Bishop f4 don't want that
team we cannot take on h7 just as i'm
sad to plated Queen age three now or all
this discovery okay let's grab the Queen
Queen is the Queen can think about mates
later root page 74 here you should be CH
five now coming it is pinned in all
kinds of ways
ya need to bring the king 26 would be
would be nice yeah it's not so much you
can do make next move all right some
wind's coming in so top ten at least
oops yeah of course how are the same guy
as before so on this time grabbing
grabbing the porn he forgot the theory
here yeah this shouldn't be too bad
winning winning champion ok so I'm
winning another move here so okay I want
to get rid of this bishop on b3 which is
quite a quite an annoying piece yeah
this looks ok now he has got the Queen
on this weird weird d 3 square maybe you
can go night h5 or something see 65 is
what I'd like to play restricting assist
knight on c3 c65 looks good young
okay to take and now i just have the
bishop pair and his Queen us oh this is
nice and now we disconnect it can you
believe this blunder the Queen and then
disconnected yeah really gotta wonder
what people are doing ok so now I'm if
he doesn't reconnect in one minute down
i'll be winning this okay i'm sorry for
any strange sounds I'm just opening this
bottle of water
yeah what to do in those waiting during
this waiting time I actually consider to
to to have some music ready for those
videos for those waiting but think you
wouldn't like it due to copyright stuff
so you need to bear with me until this
clock will be running out in two seconds
or something all right okay so 20 points
to ten points behind yeah modern defense
here this is not the most aggressive
line a bit of an accident actually it's
not bad but ok this might might still be
in a tech h5 coming maybe place h5
himself that I can just take this would
have been nice but this just destroys em
on g6 I think what should like do now Oh
staking them ok first to capture well
now ok let's go here that I maybe have
root 2 g-3
okay now I'm really I'm really on h6e
can I take ya think I can Knight takes
Queen d2 and he cannot protect h6 don't
see a move g5 is not possible because of
the pin here yeah the Sun looks like
curtains k meet alright so third place
yeah okay sometimes people play some
silly pre-move hereby Knight c3 I mean
silly it happened to me all the time
okay so we have some some French defence
IAM at once variation and a sort of ya
later somewhat strange move all items
think i think this is already a bit
weird it's not terrible but not what
what i wanted to play alright some only
i can get this night over to have five
and this is not great can just take in
group d 5
okay let's wait a bit here I don't I
don't quite know how to set up the
pieces here okay this maybe helps but
you need to retreat this bishop ok now
go here 95 95 is annoying ok maybe I can
can kick this night out with v6 or
provoke him to to exchange it ok now I'm
trying to play Bishop b5 to exchange
this bishop
yeah not great not great at all okay I
can do I can play this Queen a 50 kb
should be five years go into is six
hours so maybe he can even do it just
took them and this one here
understandable white whites are simply
better here yeah no good move this is
some sort of an admission of failure but
i need to take but maybe it's it's tall
stop label maybe it's not not good at
all okay maybe I can do Quincy monarch
Queen quince is going to reform
yeah maybe Quinn here and to form you
can check two times I can check on d 8
and then play Queenie 7 which is some
problem to put it mildly okay maybe here
at queen age 62 to cover this very very
bad position the only hope is something
like Bishop to you for and then hoping
for some we had counter-attack which
most likely will never materialize okay
but now he needs to play Queen D seven
right maybe I'm actually getting a bit
here a bit of play f3 mf3 is the problem
okay I couldn't take because of Queen f5
okay this is strange yeah he's sort of
panicked I think there was no need to do
this
yeah we had game was very bad they're
barely holding on the position together
okay yeah some Sicilian dragon oops lets
me play 96 this is the strange okay take
it yeah that shouldn't be too bad okay
maybe 95 was even better but okay just
just think for a second here right 96
Kingda 7 hmm yeah but i can i can i can
just retreat the the Queen and then
isn't a pretty awful discovery night
poor anywhere yeah this this actually I
think an maybe maybe the other one even
then we should perform
hard to believe that this game is still
going ok Knight f3 is really a checkmate
threat so double check ok night here
taking the Queen I'm not quite sure
where you should go there ok Quinn 9494
threatens knight c6 winning the the
night
and before you baby for also not bad we
can actually just take we are not this
one thought he could take before let's
just win some once material for me okay
let's let's get the King out of them
getting scary again this 93 made stuff
okay grab here yeah somehow I think it
took much longer here than the necessary
I'm training b6 now with an immediate
media maybe he allows this v6 King takes
Quincy five check and clean a five mate
besides rook a1 also also made my next
move okay it doesn't move
yeah still I don't understand why just
hard to understand okay so let's go here
clock Rock rocks okay so Italian game
here yeah quite a normal position 0 d 5
is helpful because so I might have had
five at some point okay I'm trying to
play this as obstinate as directly as
possible and it immediately paid off
joining the Queen now and the rock wall
yeah sometimes you just need to to make
those crude moves and you and you win
quickly instead of preparing all kinds
of stuff just attack immediately
yeah of course white with with
everything the whole Queen down falls
apart now okay so yeah this guy here
some really pulling away winning quickly
all the time it seems ok some like an
ARCA which one's supposed to a French
now this line is not so easy to play
with some muscles little time night XO k
didn't take and i take some before it's
the real issue here
yam this is so there should be somewhat
better for wide the some configuration
on the queenside nicely controls the c5
square so we cannot use these these
squares okay could also check with the
Queen okay both are fine I guess
yeah we should nicely place does he want
to play b5 really wouldn't mind that got
a for coming up a form
came not sure there are also other good
moves but this just just pressurizes the
a porn yeah we can just move it very
silly player me Kevin there I should
have played this differently now the
term isn't there isn't a problem for
black okay maybe this still this no this
is a problem now f6 what to see you want
to see doing okay can I actually second
h7 yeah I think I can Quinn g5g 6 Queen
h6 let's make next move and we should
have six takes is just one move longer
you will be made on g7 um yeah okay so
nice win here yeah but with a plate that
plate is really badly before
Black was think okay before you allowed
this f6 business okay share the second
place yeah I don't do so so badly yeah
but this guy's just winning quickly all
the time are pretty good at ponte a
mango 2525
k Kings Indian attack kind of position
not the most threatening opening ever
but quite solid for white and he can
wheel out all this moves quickly which
is helpful okay so not much happening
here okay so let's let's play the sir
let's keep this simple here why it is
slightly better but it's not
particularly threatening at least I hope
should I play be five okay let's play
let's put some points on white squares
first so I can can go here so not much
happening should I play be six I think I
can afford that I don't really have a
plan here okay well this is this is just
simply nothing now for white I mean I
cannot do anything as well but ok I'll
go off a draw here ok
maybe I shouldn't have done that it
doesn't really matter it's a it's
completely dead this position yambol
what this decline the draw and then
repeat smooth time okay I mean did of
course it was a draw i should just
accept and allow us both to score more
points okay is this solely on let's see
what's happening ok it's reznikoff to
plate this the solid line here with 95
yeah this line was played also in the
world championship match between Ireland
and girlfriend um I forgot what exactly
yeah something like this girl from plate
and why didn't have anything ok wants to
play a five anyway understandable ok
I'll try something here maybe it takes
I'm not sure maybe this is the
positioner miss take maybe it is Bishop
takes Queen tags and then my h3 Bishop
I'm controls CH square yeah I know but I
happy should be six coming maybe this is
bogus what I'm playing but so maybe it's
still interesting ok so now grab here
hmm interesting okay
you can take up five now I can go look
do you one here yeah I look maybe maybe
this is better attacking v6 and now
switching the bishop over to to c4 isn't
this a pin yeah I just win the night now
maybe ghost okay yeah I'm not sure that
this was such a great idea allowing him
to take take on a two
mmm it's got quite some counter play
quickly here
oh this could get ugly I am no no the
position looks maybe it is good now but
no idea very very complicated stuff yeah
whatever I'm doing and winning not quick
enough first place is just running away
okay let's let's try to speed up here
it's not exactly right here exchanging
Queens early but I didn't really think
about those moves okay so I'm just then
this is the distal end game ya know now
maybe i should actually take the drawn
to get a new game quickly yeah how to
say I mean it's not entirely dead I can
I can try this b5 pawn this week okay
huh so maybe I'm winning this pawn on
the bishop Pam yeah I got the bishop
pair hoo rah rah rah Oh ray in English
ok some maybe I can try a bit here
ok
alright so cannot avoid this in the long
run you should see one just King situ
maybe this is still a little bit okay
down 95 is just no but now I just simply
don't take the draw because of this
steady draw office i hate that i won't i
wanted to draw i would have accepted
before of course this is some really
debatable if i should should try
something here
okay maybe kinky 7 is not great not
great maybe now push the edge porn
I miscalculated here silly ok jung
impossible to do anything yeah silly
maybe I should have taken the drawing
I'm where I had to tell me I had a
little bit of something at one point I
had had those two bishops and so on ok
so 18 minutes the only chance is to
really play super quickly
alright this is complete bogus but need
to need to be quick em actually paid off
Knight f6 i-55 wanted to play pg5 moon
as a pre move but this would have been
bad so here ya 9006
it's not a clear made so battery capture
I mean I'm just a piece up and have a
strong attack I don't need to calculate
this to mate okay
okay our second place is still possible
I guess but first place no way just too
too much just too much em it's played
three games more and simply didn't
concede so many points
hmm I do need some games and once in a
while yeah I need to try that okay okay
yeah this is good maybe the Schliemann
will give me a quick win yeah this is
pretty nice already
okay let's push pieces towards the skin
I could have taken f2 already I mean
this is not bad at all but just grabbing
f2 would have been simpler the screen
moves is a bit strange not quite sure
what is doing
okay let's just grab this g3 maybe I
know I can just play Queen age five yeah
h3 is hard to defend
rook f2 maybe also possibility Queen f2
don't see mate unfortunately
isn't that made how to believe okay
let's keep this check first and then see
what what happens look look here no
don't see a maid unbelievable okay let's
prevent Queen 824 and let him make a
move
okay I'll take this piece and think
later okay check here yeah it was good
idea to just make a passing move a bit
strange okay so I'm catching up just 22
points behind and yeah okay the other
guys are just very close okay maybe you
can get some something quickly here with
this sort of Kings gambit stuff or
Vienna game stuff okay this looks nice
actually some good play on the FR Mary
okay and take on the animal on age 60
one nice pin here okay let's just grab
it
yeah and f7 is so not easy to defend it
doesn't even try so I'm a bunch of pawns
up don't want one time on F to wear with
the rook
maybe just take yeah should should be
rather simple no with four points for
the exchange
yes still have those other pawns
snot stalemate close but no stem I'd
still no sale right come on resign thank
you okay two points behind not quite
sure this guy has this last game from
eight minutes ago maybe is not finishing
the tournament this would be helpful of
course yeah more is pretty good but I
don't like to make those technical draws
its it's maybe really good but I simply
don't like it yeah I'm back adder a TED
disk full arrow again great and i lost
about a minute here in this game to
resume the recording just grade and also
we had i had checked this before the
disk space and didn't look like problem
came so a strange position i really
cannot figure this out with so little
time I don't see that this was saying
yeah well I have a piece up here and but
it's a question it's very difficult okay
i want g to
you're threatening something on d 8
maybe Quinn the AIDS almost checkmate
well
just add 20 seconds on the clock add
just
six seconds save the drone yeah of
course this game we had with just I just
had one minute minute less due to the
scrap disk space error whoo yeah this
might have cost the tournament because I
mean oh I believe won this game easily
was normal time whoo okay so what's
happening here I'm winning an exchange
here and also have a good position I
hope want to open it up here
yeah okay this this looks very nice now
this should show this one more material
yeah come on resign Thanks okay I'm
seven points behind first place with
five minutes to go pretty good opponent
okay come on I take the draw here if
want to win this thing give me some
weaker player yeah okay gambit style
usually I really suck at this come on
mate on f7 give me the mate please yeah
it's a bit a bit obvious yeah or maybe
Bishop h5 so that I can take okay this
was close sometimes them they just move
too quickly and then really overlook the
mate okay I've got a nice position
anyway cannot oops I want to play Queen
gphone well once they're still good but
24 36 was was just one with quicker no
but what now 97 the queen is hanging
yeah hmm Queen B 8 mate yep nice so two
points two points okay you have the
Schliemann again
yeah this has some potential both for
losing but also for winning quickly oops
threatening f2 now if you take screener
one is checkmate okay he attended to
this
I don't want to exchange queens so
quickly ok age my dear I can go see I
can do that what this also we can sis
fourth-ranked a bit
yeah this was system this game is just
too long too long to win the tournament
and it's not at all clear that i'm
winning or something one of the other
guys already m has one maybe Bishop
before it's a shot
threatening made and attacking the rook
rookie 4th regret one made and let's
hope the e porno still fairly solid for
white fortunately and it's got a couple
of points it's not not to know little
clear this position now that I think of
it yeah I know but matter of time here
can you just want to win on time now
what is damn quick okay I'm down to
third place heavens someone overtook me
and now I've got a pretty good opponent
again yeah yeah you simply don't win
quick enough if the opponents are just
are just better okay well pretty cool
tournament some fun games and this is
complete nonsense here c4 maybe we can
just win my bishop but okay the time is
running out so third players at the end
let's let's check this yeah super close
IAM when I had five points more and the
other guy two points more yeah I think
this game where was losing yeah this
time issue I lost one minute because of
them the dreaded disk space error
yeah this cost that this was the the
costly thing at the end maybe alright so
I hope you enjoyed it also pretty pretty
fun Tony I think and yeah let's talk
soon for new video